[Music]
all right crypto land wait isn't this
the dude who was like
yeah we're gonna have little kids on
this island or something
yeah i think it was crypto land where
they asked the creator what's the age of
consent and it was something to the tune
of um oh it was so gross it was like age
of consent for to get on the island yeah
oh yeah yeah oh no like literally what
will the age of consent be
mental maturity should be more than
enough
i'm going to throw up so this is like an
epstein island
don't throw up so they really tried to
buy an island they were gonna sell plots
of land as nfts
and did they raise money for this it was
going to be from the sale of the nfts so
they'd sell the nfts first and then buy
the island and what happened everyone's
able to buy the island
the sale did not go through because fiji
did not want to sell an island to these
guys
and crypto rules these [ __ ] creepy
crypto bro look at these guys
same thing with the constitution dao
yeah
they all just [ __ ] fail yeah
yeah dude can you imagine they go to the
fijian government they're like hey we're
the crypto guys who would like to buy an
island they're like didn't you say you'd
want to [ __ ] a kid yeah no thanks so
this was the trailer that they put out
for the whole project sick
hi this is me christopher a crypto d-gen
with a crush for crypto kitties i'm on
my way to crypto land the number one
crypto destination on earth where crypto
enthusiasts or crypto
what a horrible voice dude jesus christ
dude also
you know who does this and it's not an
nft it's just real estate the four
seasons what do you mean like
this is like every major resort does
this already and it's not an nft like
they just drop down in some country and
they're like oh yeah we'll cut up the
plots and we'll
sell this [ __ ] oh yeah well just real
estate yeah that's what i'm saying like
yeah yeah this already exists this is so
stupid yeah yeah
it's a crypto land we're gonna tell
plots it's an nft it's like it's just
real estate stupid it already exists
yeah it's been done yeah it was in real
life and when connie the founder told me
that visionary investors could own a
piece of this unique island i smash
bought one of the 60 exclusive parcels
on the blockchain hills that's how i
became a king crypto lander there it is
so are you coming to the vladimir club
party tonight yeah just for the crypto
letter nft holders right oh my god have
a nice day soon thank you
connie christopher come here dude this
looks like one of those [ __ ] up
russian cartoons for kids on youtube
yeah like the auto aided [ __ ] yeah
that's what this looks like or some
veggie tail [ __ ] it's like a thinly
veiled thing about jesus yeah underneath
yeah it's been a while yeah 50 000
blocks at least i've been waiting for
you since consensus what are you a
pending transaction well like oh [ __ ]
hell holy god damn
this makes me do not want to buy an
island there we feel that programmer
jokes were bad
yeah blockchain jokes that's a whole
nother level of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god what are you a pending
transaction
dude what i guess i'm confirmed now
ready to become a crypto land maximalist
this is crazy
have you ever dreamt of being friends
with the paperclip from microsoft word
come to crypto
dude
i'm just [ __ ] you know what i would
do if i was visiting crypto land i got
off the helicopter and like the first
thing i see is like a giant talking coin
that's what i would do
no i'm done
[Laughter]
take that [ __ ] off
just just put your headset down i can't
believe i wasted seven eat on that
what did he just say painting
transaction
[Laughter]
this animation suggests that this is how
fluid the metaverse is and it's not no
it's not laggy and shitty and no one
talks to each other it's super
anti-social yeah
is that so is is this a guy like is this
a real human being doing this or is this
like no dude it's a coin
yeah yes but i'm just like picturing
some guy like this is his job
yeah yeah clocks in like puts on his
headset and clocks in as he's like a
mascot he's like a disney
mascot hi welcome to crypto land
welcome to crypto land uh
last resort the hodlers of last resort
hot like hold on for dear lifers
no i know but of la what does that mean
of last resort maybe like you
hold on for dear life as a last resort
it's just like a horribly worded
punchline he said wellcoin
we're just gonna skip over that well
coined to crocodile no i didn't even see
that no you said it oh yeah it is
spelled out well going to crypto land i
play excuse me what'd you just say you
realize the whole point of crypto is to
put guys like you out of circulation so
shut the [ __ ] up
oh my god just threaten genocide to the
coin guy when you show up
hey thanks your days are numbered pal
oh brilliant hey stacking stats like
crazy right
honey oh my god
the community's loving it like on
twitter can't wait i just completely
missed his bitcoin t-shirt oh my god
dude everything sucks it's like they
tried to make this suck the hardest yeah
like everything sucks yeah stacking
stats like crazy right
wait for you to give me a tour connie
what do you want to see first
christopher i don't know let's start
with the best no
i always keep the best for laughs if
you're listening on audio
um picture the most annoying guy you
know and then another one of those but
he's a coin and they're talking to each
other
exactly i'm not even gonna tell you what
they look like you just know that one of
them has a bitcoin shirt and use your
imagination picture someone you [ __ ]
hate in a bitcoin shirt yeah and then
what does this shirt look like
picture it in your head yeah we won't
tell you what his looks like no i want
to tell oh you do yeah i do all right
because i feel like some of you might be
picturing a t-shirt with a bitcoin logo
on it that's not it it's way worse than
that yeah yeah you ever seen a short
sleeve
button-down vacation shirt and has
little bitcoin logos all over it you
ever like seen a button down from
supreme and you that's like 400 and you
think who the [ __ ] would buy that it's
one of those yeah exactly so there's
bitcoin yeah
let's go leave your luggage in your home
first and then i'll show you around all
the other king crypto landers have been
arriving from all corners of the world
when we get to the blockchain hills so
funny that
i i don't want to like [ __ ] it up if you
back up like two seconds
there's someone with like a like a remoa
like carry-on
you know that
expensive carry-on that everyone uses
okay
one of those people has that and it's so
funny that
it's like there are no unique ideas here
you know it's like what we made crypto
land oh yeah and i could bring my
digital ramoa suitcase yeah my fake
clutch just [ __ ]
why even do this as like humans you know
what i'm saying yeah exactly
shouldn't this be more exciting
shouldn't we be like yeah birds or
something yeah don't you want to be a
fox then i'll show you around all the
other king crypt right there i've been
arriving right by the the green
uh
verizon oh jesus yes anyway from all
corners of the world when we get to the
blockchain hills you gonna understand
what i meant by a first-class crypto
lifestyle man what is this voice hell
laughter crypto lifestyle man
excuse me
what the [ __ ] was that sir first
crypto king crypto lifestyle yeah
you know what i'm saying brother
what's the sound what's the ocular sound
[Laughter]